- What is the most, Jesus Christ.
What is the most surprising orifice
from which you have ever removed a coin.
Oh man, an ear.
I keep it real simple.
Nice try.
Hi, my name is Noah.
We are at the oldest magic store
in New York City: Tannen's.
And today, I'm answering
questions for Atlas Obscura.
Why have wands fallen out of fashion?
What would it take to bring them back?
I don't know if they're coming back.
There's one magic trick
I do with a magic wand,
and I love it cause I
get to go full Potter
and just like, I don't know.
It's so much fun.
But in general, if you
pull a magic wand out,
it just brings a lot of
associations with it.
Rabbits and capes and top hats
and all sorts of shenanigans.
What's your favorite off-the-shelf trick?
The Wonder Bubbles is my
favorite off-the-shelf trick.
You blow bubbles in the air and then
you reach out and grab one,
and it turns into a solid ball of glass.
I love that trick.
Jesus Christ, ugh.
Imagine a Venn diagram with
three overlapping circles.
Okay.
The first circle is labeled clowns,
the next, magicians, and
the final circle, comedians.
How would you label the area
where all three circles intersect?
I think I've already ran out of time
on answering this question.
Is there anything sold at Tannen's
that you can't find anywhere else?
Yes, the Tannen's mystery box.
The box contains 50 dollars worth
of incredible magical merchandise.
You buy it for 25 dollars,
but you don't get to open it
until after you leave the store,
so it's always something mysterious.
It's that right there.
Should magicians have to register
with the government like mutants?
To answer that question,
I would have to reveal
a number of compromising
pieces of information
about magicians and their mutant powers
and/or lack of mutant powers, but no.
That would defeat the purpose of it.
Also, it'd just be an
incredibly bureaucratic process.
What's the scariest thing for a magician?
Honestly, the scariest
thing for a magician
is when you meet people who
100% believe magic is real
and have a million questions for you
and things they need you to fix
and hexes they need you to break.
It's really weird, and there
are those people out there,
so that's pretty scary.
How often do you get to wear a cape?
Come on, never.
Oh man, what's more difficult.
Making things disappear or
conjuring things out of thin air?
Definitely making things
disappear is a lot harder,
because with making things appear,
you have the element of surprise.
When you make something appear,
by the time the effect has happened,
they didn't know what
to watch for, whereas,
for something to vanish,
it's almost like a question.
It just leaves this hanging problem
of where did the thing go,
so it's a lot harder to do
a really good, clean vanish.
Clowns, magicians, comedians.
Has there ever been a trick you attempted,
but it was ultimately too challenging?
I had this really crazy notion
of opening up a cardboard box and having
a single bubble fly
out, just into the air.
And I got pretty close,
but as it turns out,
it's very difficult to
get just one bubble.
Have you ever not found the card?
Yes, it's rough.
When you are a magician and
you're doing a magic show,
people just think it's part of the show,
so the more you're like,
"No it just didn't work, let's move on,"
the more they just think
you're setting them up
for something else to happen,
so it's very hard to explain to people
that it really, really did not work.
How important are physical magic shops,
like Tannen's, to magicians?
They are incredibly important.
There's certain skills and things
that you can't just learn from a video
or can't just learn from a book.
And also a place where you can meet
other magicians and exchange ideas.
I think it's really important to magic
and to learning that skill.
How easy would it be for
a magician of your caliber
to sneak a water bottle past TSA?
Part of being a magician is knowing
when it's worth it and
when it's not worth it.
And I would say, when it comes to TSA,
just like everybody else,
I would probably throw
away the water bottle
and all those kinds of things.
(laughs)
I'm gonna have to come back to this one.
I don't know if I can
think of a good answer.
What precautions does Tannen's take
to keep skilled magicians
from shoplifting?
What's the expression?
To catch a thief?
Maybe it's cause they're
good enough to not steal,
but most likely, I think
they're smart enough
to know that this is
probably not the best place
to try to steal things from,
because you will get caught
and you will get punished
in creative you couldn't
have even imagined.
- (off camera) Is there
an example of a creative punishment?
- No, we don't really create it.
We just tell them to never come back.
Yeah, it's pretty basic.
What are you hiding?
What am I hiding?
What are we all hiding?
I don't know.
I don't have that much to hide.
I think that's one of the fun things
about being a magician,
is you're very upfront.
I got a whole bunch of tricky stuff,
but it's very clear, and then you can just
be a normal person after that.
Also, a coin.